I was going to do a brand new topic,
but I didn't want to go without making
sure everyone understands the loop,
the loop problem,
because that's one problem where if you
didn't learn Newton's laws and I played
them properly, you just
couldn't figure it out. Okay.
All the other things we do in know block,
sliding down planes, friction, police,
you have an intuitive feeling for that.
But this one
really is a very non intuitive,
right?
Here's is a trolley at the top of
the track, the forces on the trolley.
What gravity and the force of
the track or bought pushing down.
And the question is why isn't it
falling down? Everything pushing down.
Why isn't it falling down?
That's the mystery.
So what's the answer you would give to
somebody says, why isn't the falling down?
Yes,
that's fine.
Yes. So they might say, well, if
you say it's falling down, oh,
how come it doesn't end up here
to the center of the circle?
Yes. You had a night. Somebody
at an answer to that? Yes.
Okay.
Pardon me.
Well,
it's just hard time.
Uh, no. There are no forces
in the horizontal direction.
The forces are all yes.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's not negligible.
Debt is an acceleration that's
producing a change in velocity.
When we say an apple has
a downward acceleration,
you let it go and it falls down. That's
what we think is downward acceleration.
Here is something which a
downward acceleration, but
it's not falling down. Yes.
Changes the direction of, of
feedback. Apple, over time,
acceleration times,
time changes.
It just changes the direction
of the velocity vector. Okay.
Yeah. I like take one more answer. Yes.
The downward component and a horizontal
component of the velocities are
independent of each other.
So the same time that the car can be
falling down in one direction to that.
All right, so let me summarize all
the different answers. First of all,
one thing you should remember,
no horizontal forces here.
The forces are what I brought. That's
the way it should be. Very, very careful.
Just because something has a tendency,
the mode to the left doesn't
mean there's a force to the left.
That's the whole point of Newton's law
forces connected or acceleration not to
velocity. So yes, this
will have an acceleration.
You cannot avoid it.
F equals m.
A we'll tell you t plus m g is m a
and a that you want in this problem.
If it moving in a circle,
M v squared over R so it is accelerating
and the difference between
this one accelerating.
Let us say I got the loop,
the loop and I drop an apple.
Forget the track. It's got an mg
acting. The owner's accelerating too.
What's the difference between these
two here you start with zero velocity,
you accelerate downwards. That means
you pick up a downward velocity.
I said this or the which is keep falling
down and picking up more and more speed.
The same acceleration is experienced by
the cart also and a little more because
tea is also pushing down,
but they're the change in velocity
over a tiny amount of time.
It's not added to zero velocity,
but to this large velocity it has at
that instant and the tiny increment and
velocity you've added this way will
produce a velocity in that direction and
what that really means if you
wait a smaller amount of time,
this thing is going along
the new velocity direction.
So that's the difference between,
so the acceleration is the same for
the falling apple as for the loop,
the loop card, but in the apple case
it has added two zero initial velocity.
So the acceleration and the
velocity or the same namely down,
if you have a huge velocity to which
you at a tiny change in velocity in the
downward direction,
you rotate the velocity vector.
That just means that as
it goes around the circle,
the velocity vector is
constantly tangent to the circle.
That's another way in which
people understand this.
If around the earth and you a standing
say on a building and you fire the gun,
it goes like that and it hits the
ground because of an acceleration due to
gravity. If you find it a
little faster, it'll go there.
They'll be certain speed at
which it keeps falling for.
It doesn't get any closer to the center.
That is in fact how you
launch a bullet into orbit.
So what's the first thing you
should do when you fired this gun?
More away because it's going to come
back and get you from behind. Okay.
All right. That's a very useful
lesson. So you might think, hey,
I sharted in that direction. It's
not my problem. Like everything else,
it'll come back and get you when you
least expect it, but this is how you have,
so it's this thing falling or not.
It is constantly falling,
but the earth is falling under that. So
it's endless search to come to the earth.
Whereas if you dropped the bullet and
he'd just fall and hit the ground,
that's what we always think us draw.
Okay.
So this is something I did in a rush
and I didn't want that because this is
really the part of physics which is not
intuitive and I think we all know what
the main part is.
The main point is velocity is a
vector and its value can change.
You're the change in direction.
Natya Indian magnitude. Yes sir.
Or changing velocity, right?
What does that equal to? Okay.
If you wait a certain time,
Delta t then the acceleration
is v squared over r put the,
we put the art, get some number, multiply
by that Delta t one 10th of a second.
That would be the change in that time.
So in that time also the guy would've
moved over and the circle a little bit
just precisely so that at that point you
knew velocity vector is tangent to the
new location.
So this little Delta v I drew,
it's not a fixed number.
It depends on how long I want to wait.
Calculuses wait infinitesimal
amount of time and practice.
Wait one femtosecond and it'll
be fine. Okay. Today is very,
very important concept I want introduce.
It's a very robust and powerful concept.
It has to do with energy.
It is powerful because after the loss
of quantum mechanics were discovered in
the subatomic world, we basically gave
up on many cherished notions. You know,
you must have heard that particles
can not have a definite position and
definitely velocity at a given time.
They don't have any trajectories.
You see a particular here now,
then you see it there.
That's true because they are observed
events. What happens in between,
you might think they have a trajectory,
but they don't force us are
not well defined because
if you don't know where the
guy is, you don't know what [inaudible]
is. You don't know about the acceleration.
So most of the ideas of Newtonian
mechanics are basically surrendered.
But the notion of energy turns out to
be very robust and survives all the
quantum revolution.
In fact,
there was a period when
people are studying nuclear
reactions and the energy you
began with them seem to be
the energy you ended up with.
So something was missing.
So Niels Bohr,
father of the atom said maybe the law
of conservation of energy is not valid.
Then Polly said, I think I put my money
on the law of conservation of energy.
I would postulate that that is some other
tiny particle that you guys cannot see
that's carrying away all
the missing energy. That is
a very radical thing to do.
In those days when people did not lightly
postulate new particles. Nowadays,
if you don't postulate a particle,
you don't get your Phd in particle
physics those days it was very radical and
the particular is not seen for many,
many years. It is called the Neutrino.
Nowadays, neutrinos are one
of the most exciting things.
One could study a lot of ministries.
The universe connected with neutrinos.
Okay, so energy is a concept you're
going to learn. Here is again,
place where it asks you don't memorize
the formulas and start plugging them in.
Try to follow the logic by which you are
driven to this notion because then it
will be less luggage for you to carry
in your head and I'll try to make the
notion as natural as
possible rather than saying,
this is my definition of energy.
This is the definition of kinetic energy.
Let's ask,
where does all that come from?
How many people have seen Kennedy
can potential energies in your past?
Okay. If you haven't seen it, that's fine.
This is not something
you're supposed to know.
If you know it and you learned
it properly, it will be helpful.
But you don't have to know that. We just
have to know what we have done so far.
So let's go back and ask simple question.
When a force acts on a body,
what is its main effect?
What does it do?
Yes.
Uh, be more precise by when
you say changes its motion,
what does it mean to change its motion?
Yes.
All right.
That's from Newton's law.
That means it changes the velocity.
So let's for the mill for a moment,
in fact, for the entire lecture today,
go back to one dimension.
Then we will do the whole business
and higher dimensions. One dimension.
Judging the velocity
simply means speeding up.
So bodies are going to speed up and
forces act on them. That we know.
We're going to find the relation
between how much speed is accumulated.
When a force acts on a body
are going to deny that.
So let us take an example where
they force is an x, that action.
And there's some constant constant
meaning. It's not varying with time.
Somebody decides to just applied
10 newtons constantly to a body.
What does that do? That produces an
acceleration, which is f over an APP,
right?
That's Newton's law.
That's a constant acceleration,
so let's go back to lecture number one.
Lecture Number One,
we learn that if a body has constant
acceleration than the velocity at the end
is the velocity squared in the beginning
plus two times a times the distance
traveled.
This part we learned long back.
This is just kinematics.
In those days we didn't ask why is
it having a constant acceleration?
You were just told that's a constant
acceleration. Just go ahead.
Now that we learned dynamics,
we know acceleration as a cost,
namely a certain force,
so I'm going to right here as you can
imagine for with them in the place of a,
but I'm going to make one more cosmetic
change and notation in all these energy
formulas.
Rather than calling the initial velocity
or initial anything with a subscript
zero and the finalists,
no subscript we're going to use in
rotation with the final quantities are
denoted with a subscript two initial
quantities had been noted by a subscript
one.
In other words,
initially the body had a Velocity v one
and then you'd had an acceleration a
farther the distance d than the relation
between final initial velocities is
this, so let's put that f over
em here and let you put a,
since we are interested in
the effect or the force,
we want to see what the
force due to the velocity.
What you find here is that if you
want to find the tangent of velocity,
of course you should take this
guy to the left hand side, right?
Take her to the other side and you want
to isolate the force of bring em over
two to the left hand side,
so do that in your head and what you get
ammo word to be two square minus m over
to the one square is f Times D.
Yeah. This is a very important concept.
It says when the force acts on the body,
it changes the velocity and it depends
on how far the force has been acting,
how many meters you've
been pushing the object.
It's clear that if you had done push it
at all than even though forces acting
velocity hasn't had time to change,
so it seems to depend on how far the
forest acted and the change is not simply
in velocity, but in velocity
square. That's what comes out.
Then you realize that it's the most
natural thing in the world to give this
combination a name because
that's what comes out of this.
That combination is called the Kennedy
Energy and I'm going to call it kid.
Too many care at the end minus
k at the beginning is f Times d
f times.
The
yes
is denoted by the symbol w
and that's called a work done.
Why f?
That's how he introduced the notion of
a force times distance of the definition
of work. This is how people, you can say,
why did anyone think of taking
the combination f Times d will.
This is how it happens,
so you need to have a unit for this,
which is actually a Newton meters,
but we are tired of calling everything
in Newton meter so we are going to call
it a jewel.
Jewel or Jay is just a
shorthand for Newton meters.
All right,
so
let us know right down the
say following expression here.
Delta K Delta K in
anything we do is a change in any
quantity is called Delta of that quantity.
Delta K is a change in k is SQL.
Do the F, time to distance travel.
Let the distance travel be
some tiny amount. Delta x,
this formula is valid even if the is one
kilometer as long as forces constant,
but I'm saying let's focus on a problem
whether the forces constant or not or
what a tiny interval in which the
body moves to distance delta x.
Then we find that the change, the
candidate energy is force times delta x.
What if there are 36 forces acting
on the body? Which one should I use?
I'm pulling and you're pushing and
it's gotta be the net force because
Newton's law connects the net force to the
acceleration.
If you and I have a tag of war and
we cancel each other out to zero,
then there is no acceleration,
so you got to go back to the definition.
This is very, very important.
This F better be the total force.
I should really use the
subscript t four total,
but I don't want to do that when we
write ethicals. I miss understood.
F is everything. We will come back
later to the notion of what happens if,
if efforts made up of two parts. So maybe
I'll just give you a simple example.
Here's a body, right, and I'm pushing it
this way and you're pushing it that way.
Let's say with equal force
and the body could be addressed or
if the body had an initial velocity,
it'll maintain the initial velocity
because velocity is for free.
Then you can ask,
what does this theater say?
This is called a work energy theater work.
Energy Theorem says the tangent energy
is equal to the work done by all the
forces.
In this case there is no change in energy
but there are two forces at work that
cancel.
Then it turns out that it's sensible
to define the work done by me
with this equals f times the distance of
travel and the work done by you will be
in fact given a minus sign.
So when do we attach a plus sign
and when do we attach a minus sign?
If you go back to the
whole innovation it was at,
it was understood that a was a positive
quantity, then everything works.
But if the body is moving to the
right and I'm pushing to the right,
then the work done by me is positive and
if you are pushing to the left and the
body is still moved to the right to work
done by you as negative. In other words,
if you get your way,
namely things move.
The way you're pushing the
work done by you is positive.
If people are pushing your counter to
your wheel in the opposite direction to
your force worked, then by you is
negative. So here's a simple example.
I have a piece of chalk and I'm lifting
it at constant velocity from the ground
is kinetic. Energy is not changing. That
means the total work done on it, the zero,
but it's not because there are no forces
on it. That is gravity acting down.
That is me countering gravity
with exactly the right amount.
I'm applying a force AMG.
So work then by me it would be positive
because I wanted to go up and it goes up.
So if it goes up by an Ahmad age work
done by me is mg times age worked on by
gravity in the meantime
is minus empty time set.
So the total work done is zero.
So this formula
says this is the total force,
but I'm telling you if you take the work
done and call it Delta w it may be a
result of many works work done by me,
worked on baby you worked on by
somebody else. Some are positive,
some are negative.
You add them all up.
So that is the notion of work done by
one of many forces acting on the body and
the total work done is the Algebraic sum
of the work done by all the forces are.
So we got this resolved.
Let's do the following.
Let us imagine all this occurs in a time
Delta t then Delta k over Delta t which
will eventually become DKD t if you take
all the proper limits becomes f times
Dxdt,
which is force times velocity.
That's called power.
So power is the rate at which
work is done. For example,
if I climate 12 story building,
I've done some work my m times g
times the height of the building,
I can claim the building in one minute,
I can climb the building in one
hour to work. Done is the same,
but the power is a measure
of how rapidly work is done.
That's why it's the product
of force and velocity.
So the units for power or jewels per
second. Now that also has a new name,
which is watts or this w
you may use a kilowatt,
which is kw,
little kid mw thousand watts.
So if you've got a 60 watt bulb,
it's consuming energy or the
rate of 60 joules per second.
That's the meaning of a 60 watt boat.
Okay.
Now I'm going to do the next
generalization, which is when the force
is not a constant but varies with x.
So do we know any example of a
force that varies with location?
Spring is one example. Even gravity,
I think we know it's not a secret.
The force of is mg near the earth.
But if you go sufficiently far,
you will noticed gravity itself is
getting weaker. It'll still look like AMG,
but g won't be 9.8 g able to become
9.6 and 9.2 and 9.1 or decrease.
But the variation of gravity in
terrestrial experiments is pretty small.
So we won what he bought it.
But the force of a spring definitely
varies with x and in order to civil away
and the force of the spring.
So one concrete example is what you
all seem to recognize is this one.
So then we have to ask what is the work
energy theory theorem when the forces
itself very,
so let's draw ourselves a force,
which is very [inaudible] is my force.
It does something f equals Kx
or minusK is a particular graph.
I'm just taking any
function of f that I want.
Now the acceleration is not constant
because the forest is not a constant.
So if you wait for one hour,
the change in Canada energy is not
simply force times distance because what
force are you going to use?
It was something now with something
later as positive, I was negative later.
So we cannot apply this formula
because F it's not a constant.
So the usual trick and calculuses
find me an interval in x.
We just saw an arrow and I'll
make it as narrow as you insist
so that during that period I think that
f is a constant and a constant value of
f is just the function f at that Timex
at that time where the location is x.
So for that tiny interval,
I can still say that fs constant or what?
Emma's some constant over the tiny
interval. Then the change in Kennedy,
Kennedy will be then F of x Times Delta X.
Yeah. Then you wait a little
longer, you go to a new place,
then you got a new value of the force.
Maybe somewhere here.
Then that times they'll tax is
the work done in that region,
but geometrically FX them.
Delta x is the area of the little
rectangle who's basest delta x and it was
hyped as the function effort at time.
So if you eventually went from here
to here, let me call that point.
The next one and let me call the ending
point is x two then the work done by you.
It's really given by
the area under the graph
and in every segment you pick up
the chain than Kennedy energy you.
You add it all up. Then we say
added all up on the left hand side.
All the case will add up to give me the
final minus initial candidate energy.
This one is what is written in
the notation of Calculus as Fx.
DX from x one two x two
this is called the integral
of the function ffx
oh again,
in a course at this level,
I'm assuming that you guys
know what an integral is.
Even if you've never heard of an integral,
if I give you a function and
you'd never heard of calculus,
you can still deal with this problem
because you will come to me and say,
give me your function.
I'm going to plot it in a some kind of
graph paper with a grid on it and I'm
just going to count the number of
pioneers squares and closed here.
That's the area and that's the chain that
Kennedy energy integration is finding
the area under graphs bounded by the
function of the top x axis below and two
vertical lines at the
starting and ending points.
Now a little digression,
even though you're supposed to know this,
I want to make sure part of the no child
left behind program that you all follow
this,
so if you never heard calculus or integral
calculus is going to be a two minute,
three minute introduction.
That is a great secret,
which is that if you give me a function
and you told me to find the area under
this from x one two x two I can go
to the graph paper and draw that are,
that is quite often a trick.
You don't have to draw anything,
you know,
and I will tell you a little more about
what it is if you give me a function ffx
the area under the graph happens to be
the following day to see another function.
Gfx can be specified in a moment and you
just have to find g of the upper limit.
Wayne at g are the lower limit
and that will be the area.
And who is this mystery function?
G Eight is any function who did
of it too is the given function.
F
okay.
So the whole business of finding area
with a solid around Newton's time is if
you have a function they want the 80 on,
did it.
You go and think of a function who is
dead of active is the given function.
So this is the opposite
of taking derivatives.
Differentiation is an algorithmic process.
You take ffx,
you add a delta x two the x,
you find the change in after wide
without tax given any function,
you can do that.
This is the opposite.
This is guessing the function g
who is delivered to the staff,
so if I say F of x
equals x cubed,
the Gfx is that function
was deliberative is x cubed.
So I know I got to start with x to the
fourth because of when I take derivatives
it'll become an x cube but
with the foreign in it.
So I fight that by putting a four
downstairs and that's the function g yes.
Okay.
Yes,
that is the plus c Betsy is
of course velocity of light.
Now why is this plus see there?
He's quite right because if you've got
a function with database or something,
adding a constant doesn't change the
date of it too. Then you can say,
well we are in trouble now because you
told me to find a function g and you're
telling me the world cannot agree on
what g is because I've got one g you got
another one with different constants.
But the beauty is that when you take
this difference, I'm in awkward.
The constant didn't.
You may put the constant but he's going
to cancel out so most of the time people
don't bother with the cons.
Sometimes it's very important to keep
the constantly plays a special role,
but we don't want that here.
We'll just call this the integral
so maybe it's again worth asking
for a second. Why is this true?
You know,
why is g the function?
Who's data Vudu is f why is
that the answer to the problem?
We had one way to think about it,
is it really more for your
completeness than anything else?
Suppose that is a function
f and I'm finding the area,
let me find it up to the point that I'm
going to call x two for the starting
point.
Let me just pick zero.
This is the ADM looking for and I rated
as FFX DX from zero to the point x two
you agreed that I say slight x do back
and forth the areas bedding with x two so
it's legitimate to call
that a function off x two
okay.
Function is anything that
depends on something else.
And we all agree that if the
point x to moves the area moves,
this is my shorthand for the area.
The starting point is nailed at zero.
This is GFX do the Lex ask
what is g of x two plus Delta?
That is the area till this point that
we in as FFX DX from zero to x two plus
Delta,
that g of x two plus Delta.
So what is the difference between the
two difference between the two is Gfx two
plus Delta minus g of x two.
If we look at the graph,
the extra area that I have is this thing
and that is clearly equal to f
at the point x to with Delta x.
Other words by how much is the area
changing? When I changed the upper limit,
well the changing by the height of the
function of the very last moment times
the change in x.
Well we know what to do and are divided
by Delta x and take the limit and you
can see that f of x two
is DG
the x at the point x too. But the
point x two is whatever point you want.
So we dropped the label and we just
say thatF as a function of Xs d GDX.
This is the origin of the result
that the area can be found.
If you can find the inverse
that of the function.
Yeah,
so let's keep a couple of
popular examples in mind.
One is f of x equals the constant.
Then GFX is he going to constant times x,
f of x equals x.
Then GFX is equal to x squared over two
as you know,
the integral of extra the Nsx to the
n plus one over n plus one that are
integral for all kinds of functions and
you check them by taking derivatives and
make sure to get back your f.
All right.
Suppose this is what we
learned from the map guys.
Then go back to the work energy theater.
I'm and see what it says.
Kid Two minus k one
oh by the way, I didn't complete
one story. Let me finish that.
This was a DFX too.
Was the area from zero to the point x too.
Gfx One is the area from
zero to the point x one.
Then there's perhaps clear to you that
if I only want the area between the
[inaudible] and the point x two I can
take the 80 all the way up to x to
subtract from it the area all the way up
to x one and that's of course the claim
that this integral
f of x Dx from x one two x
two is GFX to find is GFX.
Okay
steps. The reason the integral is
given by a difference of this g,
so let me use a shorthand notation
and call GFX to as simply Jeetu DFX.
One is do you want,
you should understand g two means
g evaluated at the final point.
Do you want to achieve out
of it at the initial point?
So you have got kid two minus K one is
g two minus g one but g is some definite
function of act.
You got to understand that for example,
it could be x to the square over two
minus x one squared over two in the
problem, but f is equal to X. Yeah.
Then let's rearrange this thing to read.
Kid to minus g two is
equal to k one minus g one
yeah,
so the work energy theorem says that
if a forces acting on a body of radial
force associated with the forest is
the function g available function of x,
who's data was the given force.
Then at the beginning if you take the
difference of Kennedy energy minus the
value of d to e be the same,
I'm sorry,
k minus d one it'll be the
same as k two minors, g two
now we don't like the form
in which this is written.
We have to make a little cosmetic change
and the cosmetic chain is to introduce
a function you affects with
this minus this function GFX
so once you do that,
you got to remember now the force is
equal to minus the deliberative at this
function because of the minus
sign of relating g to you.
Then we can write it as kid to bless
you to this k one plus you want.
And that combination,
if you call that as e two and you call
this combination is e one we are saying
[inaudible] equal to t two and that's
called the conservation of energy.
So what does conservation mean?
Conservation of energy in physics
has a totally different meaning from
conservation of energy in daily life.
Here at means when a body's moving on to
the effect of this force ffx you agree
it's gaining speed or losing speed
or doing all kinds of things.
So as it moves around it
speeding up and slowing down.
So it's speed is definitely a variable,
but a certain magic combination connected
to the velocity of the object and to
its location. You depends on x.
That does not change with time.
And there's a bit of useful to know that
does not change with time because if
you knew the value of e even able to
eat to equal to some fixed numbers,
he at one time,
you know he had all of the Times.
So let's take a simple example. So
we take a rock and we dropped it.
We know we're speaking of speed,
we know as losing height.
So you may think maybe that is some
combination of height and speed,
which does not change in this exchange.
And we find the combination by this rule.
Now in the case of gravity,F
is equal to minus AMG.
Therefore you physical the mg times.
Why?
Because mine is dod.
Why will now be my f?
Then we may conclude that
one half MV squared plus Amg,
why are the initial time will be equal
to one half m we two square plus AMG
white too at the final time
and that was the,
and the whole thing can be evaluated.
Any time you take any
random time you want,
the sum of these two numbers
doesn't change. That's the video.
Very powerful results.
So I'm going to give you one more example
later when you can see the power of
this. But in the case of
gravity, this is what it means.
So this agrees with that intuitive
notion that when you lose height,
you gain speed. When you lowered
your why, you gained speed.
But it's much more precise than that.
Instead of saying vaguely
you lose and gain one half.
Mv squared is the part
connected with the speed at mg.
Why is the part connected with height
and that some does not change with time.
So let's go back to the
mass in spring system.
In the case of mass and spring system,
if you have a mass
connected to his spring,
then we say here,
one half Mv Square plus one half k
x square equal to e is a constant.
That means find it at any initial time,
one fighter that any final
time to add these two numbers,
that portal will not change.
So let me put that to
work. Let me use that. Uh,
let me use that in a,
in a calculation.
So I say,
here's the spring,
here's where it to be.
I'm going to pull it to a new location.
A X equals zero is where
the spring likes to be.
I'm going to pull it by an amount
a and I'm going to let it go.
And I want to know how fast the guy is
moving when it comes back to say x equals
zero.
If you go back to Newton's laws,
it's a pretty complicated problem.
You've got to think about why it's a
complicated problem because you start with
a mass at rest. If you pull it by
an amount, a a force acting on it,
it'd be minus k times a that'll produce
his tiny accelerate will produce an
acceleration right k over them,
which will give it a new velocity
by the time it comes here,
but once it comes to the new location,
little later,
a different forces acting on it
because the x is now different,
so the acceleration and during this
interval is different and the gain in
velocity that interval will be different
from that in the first interval.
You've got to add all these
changes to find the velocity here.
That's a difficult proposition, but
with the law of conservation of energy,
you do that in one second.
In fact,
let's do with not just to
be at the midpoint here,
but at any point x measured
from equilibrium because
we will say initially one
half Mv,
one square plus one half k x one square
is equal to one half m B two square plus
one half k x two square.
This is the truth.
This is a constant,
does not change with time.
Now to get some mileage out of this, you
got to know what the constant value is.
Well, we know what it is in the beginning
because when we pulled this guy or that
instant,
we knew it had no velocity and we knew
it was sitting at the point a so we know
one half k square. That is the total
energy of this mass and spring system.
That's not going to change with time.
We like to say that at the initial time,
all the energies,
potential energy,
there is no kinetic energy because there
was no motion on any subsequent time.
This number has to be
equal to what you get.
Let me drop the subscript two there.
Let the Stanford some generic instant
in the future. This much we know
now do you see that we
can solve for the velocity
on any location x, you pick the x. If
you want x to be zero, that's very easy.
You kill that term.
You balance these two,
you cancel the half and you can
see there's a formula for v Square.
The square is going to
be k is where over and
that is going to be the velocity
when their swings by this midpoint.
But you can pick any x you like if they
x was not zero but 0.1 we'll put the
0.1,
take it to the other side and solve for v
this one example of the law
of conservation of energy.
So the part of the law of conservation of
energy. If you knew the initial energy,
you don't have to go through Newton's
laws and you will find an all the problem
sets and many exams when a problem has
given to you and you're told find the
velocity of something you should try
whenever possible to use the law of
conservation of energy rather
than going to Newton's laws.
So if you want to know what have we done,
how come finding the velocity seem so
difficult when I described it earlier than
Dendrite, we have done
it. The answer to this,
if you tell me the force of
the spring is a function of x.
I have done that integral in the work
energy theater them once and for all.
The integral of the spring force has
been integrated once and for all,
and that's what the
potential energy is doing.
Potential energy comes from
integrating that force.
All right,
so now let's take another problem
where there are two forces.
Act.
Yes,
I,
let me see here at the bottom of
here. Is it just me going to be
integration? Yeah, for the spring,
I think we said here,
if the force is x,
the potential energy is a g is equal
x squared over two you will be minus x
squared over to serve the forces minus Kx.
Then you have to find the you so that
minus the UDX is equal to minus Kx and the
answer that is used cake squared over two.
So if you knew the force or you just
find the function you by asking who's
derivative gives me the minus sign,
then you are done.
That's a potential
energy for that problem.
Now let's take another problem.
A masters hanging from the ceiling.
Ben has got two kinds of potential energy.
One is just the gravitational
potential energy and others,
the spring potential energy that's going
to come because k two minus k one will
be the integral of f of X. Dx.
I'm sorry. Let's call it the why.
Why the why from y one two white too.
And this f of why you will have two parts.
The force of gravity,
I'm tired of writing the limits.
Then the force of the spring
from one to two, from one to two, right?
There are two forces acting on it.
This one will be mg
white, two minus AMG. Why One?
This one will be one half k y two
square minus one half k y one square.
So every force acting on the body will
turn into a potential because the force,
Newton's law says work energy theater.
I'm applies to the total force.
The Tour de force is two parts and you
can do to integrate those eaten tegretol
is an upper limit minus lower limit of
some function. And this is what you get.
Oh, I think I made one mistake here. Uh,
I think they should give me,
yes, this is overall sinus Ron.
In these equations. Really that's
a minus in that minus, in that,
in other words,
the work done by the force.
There's only one force
acting. It's really you. One.
Mine is youtube.
You see why I got the sign wrong?
When you do the integral in calculus,
integral of FSG to minus g one but
g and you are minuses of each other,
so integral of force of give
you you initially minus,
you finally said it should really
be plus MTY one minus m g white too,
so the law of conservation of energy
for this object will be that one half MV
squared plus m g y plus one half k white
square is the total energy and will not
change this mask and bump up
and down and go back and forth.
If you knew the turtle up these
three numbers at one instant,
you know the value at any other instance.
For example,
if you pulled it from his equilibrium
by 0.2 centimeters and they released it
and you say, what's the speed?
When it's 0.1 centimeters away,
it's been easy because you know the
initial energy was all spring energy and
gravitational energy or any later time.
If you knew the why,
if you knew the position, you know the
potential in it. That's the whole point.
Potential energy depends on where you are.
Kennedy,
Kennedy depends on how fast you're moving
and some combination of value water
and how fast you're moving is
invariant does not change with time.
So if you're telling me where you are,
I will tell you how fast you're moving.
By the way, uh, I remember the
kinetic energy enters as v Square.
You can imagine when you solve for we,
you're always going to get two answers.
Why is that? Does it make any sense? Yes.
You're going to have the same
energy with your oscillating [inaudible].
If a spring is going back and forth,
are they given point x?
You can have two velocities because you
could be going away from the center or
you can be going back towards the center.
So this tells you the velocity on those
two will be donated by a minus sign,
right? If you pull the spring this way
when you go through the audit and you say,
watch my velocity, I'll get two answers
because I could be going to the origin,
I could go the other way.
And on the way back again past the origin.
So every x you will get two velocities
and that agrees well with the fact that
we squared is what you will for
and because it's quite radic,
you will get two answers and
you should get two answers.
You should be expecting that.
Okay,
now we're going to find one
bad boy, bad girl, bad person,
which is going to ruin this whole thing.
That is,
you know what I'm talking about here?
Yes.
So friction is a force acting on a body.
So what's the thing I should try to do?
Let's take a body with the
only friction acting on it.
Let's not worry about anything else
or maybe friction at the spring.
So I try as usual to get
a law of conservation of
energy and friction is acting
and you will see that I will not succeed
and it looks like everything
here is watertight, right?
Everything looks good.
You'll tell me the force acting on a body.
I integrate the force from start to
finish and I call that the difference or
potential energies.
Then I've got my results.
Try to follow this logic with care.
Two minus Kevin has integrated the force.
Integral is GX two minors,
dx one or which is UX one minus UX too.
You can rearrange it to get care to
plus you to escape and plus you want,
it looks like you can always get la
conservation of energy and we want to know
why that fails when there is friction.
Why does it fail when there's friction?
So when there is friction,
let me try to do it again.
Can't two minus k one is the force
due to the spring with this whatever,
minus k x. Let me do that. Integral
plus the force of friction.
DX from x one, two x two.
This one is from x one,
two x two and we saw what this is.
Let me write it one more time.
One half k x one square is
one half k excuse squared.
If you didn't have friction,
you are done because you can get kinetic
plus potential for spraying is Kennedy
plus potential.
Why don't we just integrate
the force of friction
and then
turn that into a u and then we're done.
What's going to be the problem? Let me,
let me just give some,
anybody else want? Yes.
Uh,
there would be always we change direction.
Okay.
What does your
can associate a potential function?
Friction.
Because it depends on the path that will
lead the initial position in the final
vehicle.
He considers the final and the additional
right, but let's suppose I'm somewhere
and I'm pulling a block and there is some
friction that is a force F
at the location. That's my f.
Why don't they just use the value of f?
Yes.
Pardon me.
I know, but see you are saying
something else which is speaking.
I head into into the book but right now
what's the problem with integrating the
force of friction?
Yes.
I was just going to say
[inaudible] the one in the system.
No, but you're all telling me why
that is a loss of mechanical energy,
but I'm just a mathematician. I'm
saying give me a force. Find Integrity.
What's the problem?
Yes.
All right.
Is it because the function for the course?
Yes. I think somebody else
said that earlier. Also,
the force of friction
is not a function of x.
You might say,
what do you mean I'm pushing this guy.
I know how hard is pushing me back,
but I'm telling you not push it
the opposite way than you'd find.
The force of friction at the very same
location is pointing in a different
direction.
Where does the force of his spring is?
The force of the spring.
It's minus k x.
Whether they are going towards the spring
are going away from the spring. Right?
Think about that.
Same with gravity.
Gravity is pulling you down with the
force minus mg and it doesn't care whether
the chalk is going up or
coming down on the way up.
It's pulling it down on the way down
is also pulling it down because at the
given location that is a fixed force,
so the problem is not the
force Beatty's with x or y,
but the force is a function only affects,
but if the function of x and velocity
then you also have to know the velocity
and no one's giving you then definite
value for the velocity because of the
vibrating mass in spring
velocity can have either signed,
therefore we do this integral
but we don't do this.
Even though I write it this way,
mathematically is wrong because the force
of friction is it really a function of
x? I'll tell you in what limited since
it is a function and what technical
sensitive spot,
let's defer that for now.
Take all these guys to the left hand side,
so this is Cape too.
This'll become youtube so you
will get kid too. Plus you two
minus k one plus one is
equal to this last thing.
Then by friction the x from x one two
x two and the question is can I do the
integral? The answer is if you just
tell me x one and x two that no,
that's the point you're making.
I cannot just do an integral because
I will have to know the whole story,
but in limited cases I can do this.
Suppose I pulled the mass by an emote a
and I let it go,
but now that is friction.
I think we all know that
if it can be at the center,
it won't be going quite as fast and we
also know when it overshoots the other
side, it will not go back to minus say
normally it would go back to minus eight.
Everyone knows why it goes
back to minus a right.
When you go to the other
extremity without friction,
you're energy is all potential. If
there's one half k's square to begin with,
it's got to be one half k squared at
the end except ache and become minus day
without changing the answer. That's
why you go from a two minus minuses,
but when you got friction cannot say
the energy at equal cause I got do this
integral for this part of the
journey from here to here.
During that part, the journey, the
force is a well defined function.
Namely it is a constant value minus
mew times mg and it is acting this way
so but this part of the trip I can do the
integrators very easy to find out what
it is.
It's minus M g times music,
kinetic times the distance traveled.
Of course there's a
little more complicated.
Now you have to tell me where
you want your velocity's.
You might say find the velocity at x
equal to zero if you want me to do that.
The distance is travels is
the original displacement.
That's what is the stuff on that site
and here cape to is one half Mv Square,
which is what I'm trying to find.
I am on the origin so it's one
half kid times zero square,
no potential energy initially that it
was no candidate energy but that was
potential energy.
One half k square.
You follow that logic.
Now this is the difference in energies
due to the conserved forces that are
conserved energies,
but the difference e two minus e one
is no longer zero but is given by this
number so I can calculate it
for this part. I can even ask.
This is one of the homework problems.
I think you are asked,
how far does it go to the left?
Well what do you do?
Let's call the place where it goes to,
to the leftmost extremity as a prime.
Then we don't know.
So there when you go to the k two plus
you two minus k one plus you one you will
go back to this formula.
First of all,
the distance that the force of friction
acts on is how much is a distance a to
come here and another day
prime to go to the left.
A prime is a magnitude of
how far do you go to the left
and likewise on the left hand side you've
got to have the throat candidate plus
potential miners. Kinetic plus
potential are the end of the day.
You only have potential energy.
One half k n Prime Square,
no candidate in initially. Again,
you only had potential energy,
one half k square.
You will see that a prime now satisfies
a quadratic equation. They can solve it,
but what is the point?
The point is you cannot do this integral
once and for all and say the answer
depends on the on the end points
in this particular problem.
If you're told me you're doing this part
of the journey during that part of the
journey, because for the entire trip,
the velocity had a particular sign,
namely to the left force.
The friction had a definite and
magnitude and sign namely to the right.
And then of course it's as good as any
legitimate function and you can do the
integral. In fact, the
force is a constant.
You can pull it out of the integral and
integral dx is just the distance travel.
Okay,
so work done by friction and they will
always come out negative and you should
keep track of that.
Okay,
so the final bottom line
for law of conservation of
energy that you guys should
remember is the following.
You take all the forces acting on a body,
so let's do it one more time in our head
so you know where everything comes from.
Everything comes from this result.
K Two minus k one which is the work
done is the integral of all the forces,
the forces into forces that depend on
location only and not on anything else
like velocity.
Let me just divide them into two forces.
One is the good force at Dx
and one is a force of friction.
Yes,
this guy will turn into
potential energy difference.
Let me just take one good force and the
force of friction if he had to eat will
generate its own potential.
When you do the integral,
then we made then say e two minus e one
effect the same as k two plus two minus
k one plus one is equal to the work done
by friction work done by friction is
the shorthand for that integral,
which you can do only you must divide
the motion involved into pieces.
For example, if you have a massive
swing to the left, then turns it on,
goes back to the right. Of course. Again,
it won't come back to the original
AEL company, smaller number.
That's because there's more loss
of energy on the return trip.
For the return trip. You must do the
problem separately on on the return trip.
You start from this a prime that you
found that started moving to the right,
no friction will act to
the left soon as Dubai,
the Morson at the segments
during each segment,
the force should have a definite
direction and magnitude so you can do the
integral.
The point is there is no universal
formula for ffx due to friction,
so in one dimension, that's all it
is. Between the good and bad forces,
those which lead to potential,
those were don't the differences.
The good forces are functions of x bad
forces at functions of x and something
else so that are they given x.
It's possible to have two
values for that function.
Bathymetrically we don't
call it a function.
That's why you cannot do the
integral once and for all.
So this is the law of
conservation of energy. Okay?
All right.
Now what I have to do
here for the remaining time is a little
more of some mathematical preparation
for what I'm going to do next.
What I'm going to do next is to go to
higher dimensions and we got to make sure
we all know some of the mathematical
ideas connected with higher dimensions.
So I'm going to start off with some
things and this is like a mathematical
interlude. Again, I told you if you're
not strong on some of these things,
you should read this math book I
mentioned to you on basic training.
We'll certainly cover these topics,
but you don't have to have that.
I'm going to tell you now how to do it.
So the math idea that I'm going to use
this really a mathematical digression to
make sure everybody knows.
They're very simple things,
but we do it all the time in physics.
So I want to make sure you guys can also
do that. So let's take some function
ffx that looks like this.
This is f of x,
this is x.
And let's say you start here at some
point x and I'm going to go to the nearby
point x Plus Delta X.
Delta x is exaggerated so you can see it,
so it's actually in the end
going to be a very small number.
Okay.
The question is what is the change in the
function in going from here to here so
we all know what it is that
is a change in the function.
Okay.
We are going to need approximations
to the change of the function.
Okay.
Useful approximation is to say,
let's put it on the function as a straight
line and keeps going with the slope
it had to begin with.
Yeah.
You can see that if the function is
not curving up or down two months,
you almost got the right change in f
and what does that change in f?
That change in f is the
derivative of the functions
at the point x times the change in x.
Okay,
but it is not an equality
is not inequality because
that is this little guy on
the top that you have missed because
the function is not following the same
slope that you have to begin with.
It's curving up.
So let's take a concrete example.
Suppose ffx is equal to x squared,
then F of x Plus Delta x is x squared
plus two x Delta x plus Delta x squared.
Therefore the change in after you
got to take her to the other side,
pain change your Naf is two x
Delta x plus Delta x squared,
two x Delta Act two x is of course
what you realize is the delivery.
We have to function at that point
and that's giving you this part,
but that's a tiny portion on the top
which is delta x squared that you're not
getting
the function as x cube at x to the
fourth that hyperbolic Karsh affects.
That'll be more editors,
but the point is the change in the
function has the leading piece that's
proportional delta x.
Then the correction that
we say mathematically are
of higher order in Delta x,
so you've dealt,
the x is made very small but not zero.
Then it a bit of useful formula to know
that the change in function and going
from one point to another point is
this rate of change times to change.
I don't think anything could
be more natural than that,
but we should be comfortable
by saying, uh, it's natively.
People say,
well,
you should do that because in calculus
you're canceling this delta x with that
dx.
That's not what we're really doing.
We all know that the
Stanford a certain limit,
but the limit stance literally for
the slope, which is at that point,
so he functions had only one slope and
they never changed the slope and he knew
that slope.
Then if you know the value to begin with,
you can find the value of miles away
from where you are because it's going at
the same clip.
But most functions,
of course we'll change the slope and for
that reason the Fed will be an error in
the formula you get if you use this.
But if delta x is very,
very small and it's your end,
is your intention in the end to make very,
very tiny delta axes,
then we say we will use this approximate.
That's pretty simple,
but it's very useful to know.
So let's take a example of this function.
Have this rule because I'm
going to use it all the time.
So one example is f of
x is equal to one plus x
to the N.
Well f one
it's just one.
Suppose you go to a nearby point
which is x away from the 0.1.
So this x is really like your delta x.
Then the change of the function,
we be DF DX
at the 0.1 times the change in x.
Yes,
I'm sorry. Ah, okay. That's
right. F of zero if you like.
If x is equal to zero,
the function as a value one.
Okay.
Then if you go to the neighboring point,
so here's what I'm saying, function.
There's something, it's a value. Here is
one and I wanted to go to a nearby point,
which I'm calling x.
Then dfds do you know is n times one
plus x to the n minus one same sex,
but do you have to evaluate it at
x equals zero so this goes away.
Then you get an x.
So the tangent,
the function,
this function as you move
off x equals zero is annex.
So what we're saying then is one plus
x raised to the n is one plus n x plus
tiny numbers.
If x is small,
that is the videos for the zone.
If something looked like one
plus x raised to a power,
and if you're not going too far from
the 0.1, namely Fedex is very small,
then don't bother with doing the whole
one plus x times one plus x and times
it's approximately
equal to one plus annex.
Yes.
So let me give you one example.
You will, we'll use this later on.
According to relativity,
a master for particle
is given by this.
It's a body sitting still. It has
certain mass, Newtonian mechanics.
We say the mass is the mass and
left at the end of the activity.
You don't have to know
the audits in of this.
That will be taught to you in due course,
but it just says particle to the velocity
have a mass different from when they
are at addressed and this is the
velocity and sees the velocity of light.
This is the exact formula.
No,
most of the time you don't care about
it because we oversee maybe 10 to the
minus 10 and a square of that standard.
The minus 20 and one minus certain number
is negligible and be just put it as
one. Suppose you want an answer
that's good too. Some accuracy.
I will write this as follows.
This m zero times one minus B squared
overseas square to the power minus one
half. You agree that's what
a squid or in the bottom is.
It's this power upstairs.
Now we can write it as fall asm zero.
This is one plus x to the N.
Okay,
so the x that we use is minus B squared
overseas square and the end that we use
is minus a half.
Yeah,
that's what I'm using in this formula x
is minus B squared overseas square and
n, which is the power to with
embracing is minus half. Therefore,
this is equal to one plus B squared over
two c square plus corrections with a
negligible if v squared over
c squared is very small.
This is a bit useful result.
It tells you the mass variation is that
it's the mass at rest plus m zero be
square or two squares.
A very useful formula.
Sometimes this formula is much more
friendly to use than the formula.
You cannot beat the exact formula.
It's the exact truth.
But if you're interested in that exact
function for small values of v Oversee,
it's much more useful to
you as this approximation.
Yeah,
and you will have lot of problems like
this in your homework now or later
everywhere else.
So if I'm going to use it all the time,
I should tell you what is this. So let
me summarize what I've told you so far.
First result is if a function is known
at a certain point and you want an orange
value at a nearby point,
what are you supposed to do
that's not so hard to guess,
right?
For example,
their tuition costs are so much this year
at Yale and we know how much is going
up every year. You can make a guess
on what there'll be a year from now.
Of course,
in reality it will be higher than that
because there are these other terms,
but that's the best guests you would make.
That's how we predict the future
by looking at past rates of chains.
That's pretty normal.
The point is that you can predict
the tuition a year from now, maybe,
but maybe not five years from now or 10
years from now because there's inflation
on top of inflation.
That's like saying the rate of
change itself has a rate of change.
The slope here is not
the same as a slope dead.
That's what the higher derivatives
of the function do for you.
So I will conclude by
telling you one last result,
which I'm not going to prove in
this course and you guys should uh,
learn from the math department
the following result.
That is some crazy function.
Okay,
listen ffx I want to know
what it is at the point x,
I know what it is at the origin.
If I know nothing else,
how do I predict the future value of x?
Meaning for other wrecks,
I don't know my best guesses.
Well,
this the number I knew
that's what is going to do,
but if I knew its rate of change here,
you know it's slow slope here.
The next guest is the of it
to of f at the origin time.
Sex. That just what I did earlier.
Instead of Delta X, I'm calling it x.
If x is small enough, it'll work,
but of course x need not be small.
If it gets bigger, it turns out you
can do a little better by adding this
is the second derivative of the
function or the origin times x square
and you can go on adding more and more
terms. I'll just add one more term,
which is three factorial times d cubed,
x f over D,
x cubed times x cubed.
This goes on forever
and it says that if you knew every deliver
to where the function or the origin,
you can reconstruct the function,
not just infinitesimally close to it,
but as far as you want to go that are
some mathematical restrictions on this
because there are infinite
number of terms in this thing.
When you add them all up, you may get
infinity, which would be nonsense,
so he's really sum up this
infinite number of terms.
If they add to finite
number and if they do that,
we'll give you the function here.
What we have done is to just use the first
two terms as an approximation or what
what I'm telling you,
there's is something called the Taylor
expansion of a function that allows you
to know the function.
Even here macroscopically far from here,
if you knew all the date of it is and if
you put those data natives here and if
the some added up to something finite,
that finite thing is the value
of the function or the new point.
Here's an example.
You guys can take ffx equals e to the x.
Why don't you go home and work out
the cities for Ffx at all points?
You've got to remember that either the
x has the beauty that it did have it.
It was either the exit itself and its
value or the origin of every delivered
with simply one,
so this just becomes one plus x
plus x squared over two factorial.
That is in fact the
expression for these are the x
and it turns out that no matter how big
xs the some in fact adds up to find that
number that we call e to the x
in particular. What is he itself?
He itself is either the one he is
either the one support x equaled one.
You get one plus one plus one square
over two factorial plus one cubed over
three factorial. You do all that, you
get two point something, something,
right? That's e. So this
is a very powerful notion.
If you knew all the
derivatives of a function,
you can predict there's value in not only
the tiny neighborhood put over the big
distance. If you knew the first derivative
and you were not very ambitious,
look, the logic is very
simple. If x is a tiny number,
x squared is even Tinier at Xq blood.
Even tiny.
We got no respect for these terms.
We disrupt them and we stop here.
Okay, I'll have something more to
say about this later on, but for now,
these ideas will be useful for
what we're doing next time.